La semaine dernière, nous avons donc abordé le chapitre 6 d'Ézéchiel.
Et dans ce chapitre, nous étions en train de voir que Dieu qui avait jusqu'à présent annoncé la destruction de Jérusalem,
était en train de conduire Ézéchiel à annoncer la destruction du pays d'Israël dans son ensemble.
Et lorsqu'il était en train d'annoncer ce jugement, je suis en train de résumer ce que nous avons vu dans les versets 1 à 7,
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous allons nous concentrer sur les versets 8 à 10.
Donc sur les versets 1 à 7, excusez-moi.
Donc Dieu était en train de prendre la création à témoin par rapport au péché d'Israël.
Et Dieu était en train de souligner la destruction qui allait arriver parce qu'Israël avait adoré sur des hauts lieux.
Alors c'est important de préciser que quand on parle de hauts lieux, ce sont des hôtels qui avaient été construits pour adorer des divinités.
Et lorsque Israël est rentré dans la terre de Canaan, déjà Dieu précise à un moment que le jugement pour lequel il chassait les nations dans la terre de Canaan et qu'il donnait cette terre à Israël,
ce n'était pas le mérite d'Israël, c'était parce que déjà ces nations avaient péché et leur péché était arrivé à son comble.
Et ils avaient déjà pratiqué le péché d'idolâtrie.
Et donc Dieu décidait de les punir, de les chasser et de donner cette terre à Israël.
Donc quand Israël est rentré dans la terre promise par Dieu, à Canaan, il y avait déjà des hôtels, il y avait déjà des hauts lieux,
il y avait déjà des hauts lieux d'anciens, de divinités qui étaient adorés.
Et Dieu leur avait demandé de détruire ces choses, de les effacer.
Mais ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'au fil du temps, ces hôtels n'ont pas été détruits.
Et ces hôtels ont été une occasion de chute pour Israël.
Et donc Dieu leur dit un moment, il leur précise maintenant qu'à cause de ce péché, je ferai venir l'épée contre vous,
je vais détruire ces hauts lieux qui n'ont pas été détruits depuis des siècles,
je vais dévaster ces hôtels, ces statues dans lesquelles vous placez votre confiance seront détruites,
et je ferai même tomber vos morts devant vos idoles.
Et Dieu précisait même que, par rapport à ça, c'était pour préciser combien ce péché d'idolâtrie,
qui avait ouvert la porte même à d'autres péchés plus graves,
avait été même la source même du jugement d'Israël.
Parce que déjà, ils n'avaient pas obéi à Dieu, le premier commandement qui était d'enlever l'idolâtrie dans l'ensemble du pays,
ils ne l'avaient pas fait.
Donc, jusqu'à présent, nous voyons, nous avons vu, nous avons vu en effet que dans le livre d'Ézéchiel,
que nous avons abordé depuis le début, nous avons vu que le livre concerne,
pour résumer, je peux même dire résumer les cinq premiers chapitres,
nous avons vu que Dieu était en train d'annoncer le jugement sur Jérusalem et le pays d'Israël.
Mais maintenant, dans les versets 8 à 10, dans lesquels nous allons méditer ce matin,
nous voyons à un moment que cette fin n'était pas l'acte final du plan de Dieu.
Dieu est en train de préciser, donc pour rappel, nous allons lire les versets 8 à 10,
nous disent, je fais le rappel,
« Mais je laisserai quelques restes d'entre vous qui échapperont à l'épée parmi les nations,
lorsque vous serez dispersés en divers pays.
Vos réchappés se souviendront de moi parmi les nations où ils seront captifs,
parce que j'aurai brisé leur cœur adultère et infidèle,
et leurs yeux qui se sont prostitués après leurs idoles.
Ils se prendront eux-mêmes en dégoût, à cause des infamies qu'ils ont commises,
à cause de toutes leurs abominations.
Et ils sauront que je suis l'Éternel,
et que ce n'est pas en vain que je les ai menacés de leur envoyer tous ces mots. »
Donc Dieu est en train de préciser que la ruine sera totale,
mais Dieu précise aussi qu'il va conserver un reste malgré la dureté du jugement.
Donc ce que Dieu est en train de préciser dans les passages que nous avons lus,
ce n'est pas que ceux qui allaient échapper à ce jugement
étaient beaucoup plus justes que les autres,
ou qu'ils étaient beaucoup plus malins.
Parce qu'on pouvait aussi se dire à un moment que,
même là dans leur compréhension,
ils pouvaient se dire qu'ils ont été plus malins pour fuir en Égypte,
ou plus malins pour...
Non, Dieu est en train de préciser que c'est Dieu qui décidait,
dans sa souveraineté,
c'était annoncé à l'avance,
que Dieu décidait de les épargner dans sa souveraineté.
Et donc, la vérité que nous pouvons voir au travers de ce texte,
de ce texte sur lequel nous allons méditer ce matin,
c'est que malgré des siècles de désobéissance,
malgré le fait que Dieu apporte un jugement qui témoigne de sa sainteté,
Dieu est aussi en train d'apporter un jugement qui témoigne de sa miséricorde.
Et notre question ce matin,
c'est de savoir pourquoi Dieu a décidé d'épargner un reste.
Pourquoi Dieu dit à un moment,
je détruirai une partie de votre peuple,
mais il en restera un reste.
Pourquoi Dieu décide d'épargner un reste,
et quel est le but que nous devons comprendre
lorsqu'il était en train d'épargner ce reste.
Et donc, ce premier point, c'est
pourquoi Dieu décide d'épargner un reste parmi le peuple d'Israël.
Donc, le verset 8,
« Mais je laisserai quelques restes d'entre vous
qui échapperont à l'épée parmi les nations
lorsque vous serez dispersés en divers pays. »
Donc, ce reste allait être composé de ceux qui avaient échappé
en fuyant dans d'autres nations,
parce que lorsque Babylone envahit le royaume de Juda,
parce que le royaume du Nord a déjà été détruit par la Syrie,
quelques années avant,
maintenant c'est Babylone qui est la nouvelle puissance dominante,
qui décide de prendre le royaume de Juda.
Et donc, quand ils font le siège,
il y a quelques juifs qui ont réussi à fuir.
Ils ont réussi à fuir en Égypte,
ils ont réussi à fuir dans quelques nations.
Il y a d'autres qui ont été déportés dans les territoires.
Donc, à un moment, Babylone avait déjà fait une première entrée dans Jérusalem.
Ils ont pris une partie du peuple.
Donc, là-dedans, vous avez des éléments comme Daniel, Ézéchiel,
qui ont été déportés et qui ont été emmenés à Jérusalem,
ainsi que le roi qui était en place.
Et donc, Dieu parle à ce reste.
Il y aura ce reste qui aura fui dans les nations.
Il y aura ce reste qui est déporté et qui est maintenant en esclavage
dans les territoires sous l'administration des Babyloniens.
Et rappelons-nous, quand nous avions médité dans le chapitre 5, au verset 12,
il était rappelé que Dieu allait tirer l'épée.
C'est-à-dire que Dieu allait apporter l'épée
après ceux qui étaient dispersés, après la chute du pays.
Mais Dieu promet quand même de les épargner.
Parce que le jugement de Dieu était tel que Dieu dit
« Même ceux qui auront fui dans les nations alentours,
mon épée les poursuivra là-bas. »
Donc, c'est ce qui s'est passé.
Quand Babylone a fini de prendre Jérusalem, le royaume du Juda,
Babylone s'est tournée vers l'Égypte.
Ils ont même battu l'Égypte.
Ensuite, ils sont allés prendre l'Égypte.
Et donc, les Juifs qui avaient fui en Égypte ont retrouvé la guerre.
Ceux qui avaient fui dans les nations voisines,
Babylone aussi les a attaqués.
Donc, comme nous l'avons vu dans les versets précédents,
Dieu est en train de préciser
que le jugement contre les idoles et leurs adorateurs
allait faire que personne ne serait épargné dans Jérusalem.
Donc, dans la situation de Jérusalem,
tous ceux qui étaient dans Jérusalem
allaient recevoir le jugement.
Donc, ceux qui ont pu fuir,
ce sont ceux qui étaient en dehors de Jérusalem
qui avaient pu fuir,
ceux qui avaient été déportés.
Mais à l'intérieur de Jérusalem,
tous ceux qui ont essayé de fuir ont subi le jugement.
Et pourquoi Dieu est en train de préciser ça ?
C'est ce que nous avons lu dans les versets 4 à 6
qui vont nous parler à un moment
que Dieu permettrait qu'il y ait des cadavres devant les idoles.
Parce qu'à un moment,
ceux qui étaient restés à Jérusalem,
ils s'étaient cachés parce qu'ils étaient sûrs
que Jérusalem ne pourrait pas tomber.
Ils étaient sûrs.
Et ils étaient sûrs déjà que Jérusalem ne pouvait pas tomber.
Ensuite, ils étaient sûrs que l'Égypte allait venir les secourir.
Donc, à cause de cette assurance,
malgré tout ce que Jérémie avait dit,
parce que si vous lisez en parallèle le livre de Jérémie,
c'est sur cette période,
vous allez voir que Jérémie ne faisait que les mettre en garde.
Jérémie leur disait,
même l'Égypte voudra venir à votre secours,
mais l'Égypte n'arrivera pas.
Nebuchadnezzar écrasera l'Égypte.
Mais malgré cela,
ils étaient sûrs qu'ils allaient être protégés à Jérusalem.
Alors, quand Dieu apporte le jugement à Jérusalem,
il n'épargne personne à Jérusalem.
Même le roi,
Cédéciaz,
qui a essayé de fuir,
il a essayé de fuir la nuit.
Lorsque les Babyloniens sont rentrés dans Jérusalem,
il a essayé de fuir la nuit,
mais il a été attrapé,
avec quelques-uns de ses conseillers,
de ses gardes du corps.
Il a été amené à Babylone,
et là-bas, il a été jugé,
ils lui ont percé les yeux,
et ensuite, je crois qu'il a été tué,
ou des choses comme ça.
Mais là, Dieu est en train de dire,
« Du reste,
que ce soit ceux que j'ai déportés,
que ce soit ceux qui ont fui,
je les épargnerai. »
Ils ne sont pas en train de fuir
parce qu'ils ont eu beaucoup plus de chance que les autres.
Ils sont en train de fuir
parce que moi, j'ai décidé qu'ils fuient.
Ces passages sont...
Je vous parlais déjà,
si nous méditons sur ces aspects,
c'est étonnant de voir comment
Dieu parle de choses.
Même ces choses,
il est en train de préciser ces choses
presque sept siècles
avant que cela ne se passe.
Il est en train de préciser
qu'il y en a qui fuiront,
mais que c'est Dieu qui a décidé.
Et c'est important de voir
parce qu'on pourrait encore se dire,
c'est le hasard,
parce que historiquement,
lorsque vous étudiez par exemple,
des cas d'historiens,
lorsqu'il s'agit de...
Par exemple,
lorsque Dieu va...
Dieu annonce...
Esaïe va annoncer la venue de Cyrus.
Il va annoncer...
Donc, le peuple va être déporté à Babylone,
mais Dieu dit,
« Au bout de 70 ans,
vous serez libérés
et vous pourrez revenir sur cette terre. »
Et il y a des historiens qui vont dire,
« Au moment,
ils n'arrivent pas à expliquer
qu'Esaïe ait pu annoncer la naissance de quelqu'un,
et même annoncer le nom de la personne
avec précision,
plusieurs années avant,
avant même la naissance de Cyrus. »
Esaïe dit,
« Cyrus,
j'étais choisi pour pouvoir libérer Israël
pour qu'il revienne. »
Et les historiens vont dire,
« Au moment,
lorsque Cyrus libère Israël,
il a aussi libéré d'autres peuples,
ils vont dire,
« Mais non,
c'est une coïncidence,
c'est des choses qui... »
Mais nous voyons quand même
que ce sont des choses qui sont avancées
et qui sont annoncées des années avant.
Et même dans l'histoire,
quand vous regardez l'histoire,
il y a très peu de peuples
qui ont été détruits
et qui ont pu se relever.
Très peu.
Il n'y en a même pas beaucoup
dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
Vous allez voir,
je prends même le cas de la Syrie
ou de Babylone même,
qui ont été détruits.
Ce sont des royaumes qui étaient puissants.
Et aujourd'hui,
on parle...
Quand nous lisons la Bible,
nous voyons Ninive,
nous voyons Babylone.
Ninive et Babylone,
les gens doutaient même
que Ninive et Babylone
aient pu exister.
Elles ont été retrouvées
pratiquement au 19e siècle.
Parce qu'à un moment,
quand le jugement de Dieu
a frappé la Syrie, Babylone,
aucun de ces royaumes
n'a pu se relever.
Aucun des restes.
Parce que même là,
les Babyloniens ont fui
dans des nations, tout ça.
mais n'ont pas pu reconstituer la nation.
Mais là,
Dieu est en train de dire
la nation sera détruite,
vous serez déportés,
vous allez fuir
dans notre nation,
mais moi,
je vais permettre
que vous reveniez plus tard.
Donc déjà,
je vous dis,
c'est un cas rare
et nous voyons déjà
la souveraineté de Dieu.
Et donc,
c'est ce premier point.
Pourquoi Dieu décide
de les épargner ?
C'est parce qu'à partir d'eux,
Dieu allait continuer son plan.
Le plan de Dieu
ne s'arrêtait pas là.
Le problème,
c'est qu'Israël
n'avait pas compris
le plan de Dieu.
Le plan de Dieu,
c'était qu'Israël
soit une lumière
pour les nations,
Israël soit
la terre
qui allait accueillir
le Messie.
Et le Messie
n'était pas juste
réservé pour être
le sauveur d'Israël.
Le Messie était réservé
pour être le sauveur
de l'humanité.
Et Israël devait donc
être la terre d'accueil.
Israël n'avait pas compris ça.
Et Israël
avait plongé
dans le péché
d'idolâtrie.
Donc,
qu'est-ce que Dieu va faire ?
Dieu va purifier,
va nettoyer Israël.
Et à l'issue
de cette purification,
il va les ramener
sur cette terre.
Et à partir de là,
le plan de Dieu
va pouvoir se poursuivre.
Donc,
voilà pourquoi
Dieu a décidé
de les épargner.
Mais maintenant,
qu'est-ce que nous pouvons
encore comprendre
un peu plus ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il voulait
leur enseigner
en les épargnant ?
Et qu'est-ce qu'il voulait
même enseigner aux nations
alentours
en permettant
à ce reste de survivre
et de revenir plus tard ?
Le verset 9
« Vos réchappés
se souviendront de moi
parmi les nations
où ils seront captifs
parce que j'aurais brisé
leurs cœurs adultères
et infidèles
et leurs yeux
qui se sont prostitués
après leurs idoles
et se prendront eux-mêmes
en dégoût
à cause des infamies
qu'ils ont commises
à cause de toutes
leurs abominations. »
Qu'est-ce que Dieu
est en train de nous dire
quand nous lisons
le verset 9 ?
Il est en train de nous dire
que ce reste
n'allait pas seulement
être épargné
mais ce reste
allait aussi se repentir.
Dieu l'annonce
à l'avance
et parce que Dieu
l'annonce à l'avance
nous réalisons même là
que la repentance
est un don de Dieu.
Nous voyons même
que là
la repentance
qui allait se produire
pour que ceux
qui vont rester
dans les nations
aient revenir
pour reconstruire,
ceux qui sont
à Babylone
ou même
dans d'autres nations
et qui vont être libérés
par leur vainqueur
plus tard
allaient se repentir.
Dieu est en train
de nous révéler
ces choses à l'avance
et c'est comme ça
que ces choses
se sont produites.
Quand nous lisons
le livre de Daniel
nous voyons
comment Daniel
va intercéder
dans ce sens.
Nous voyons
les intercessions
des Haïts,
de Jérémie
de l'ensemble
des prophètes
parce que c'est aussi
important de voir
que l'ensemble
des prophètes
à cause de ce péché
d'idolâtrie
tous ces prophètes
avaient annoncé
la destruction
de Jérusalem.
En tout cas
tous les prophètes
qui étaient avant
la destruction
parce qu'après
vous avez
quelques prophètes
comme Zacharie
qui vont venir
plus tard.
Mais ce que
Dieu était en train
de dire
c'est que ce reste
allait se repentir.
Ce reste
allait échapper
au jugement.
Dieu était en train
d'épargner leur vie
afin qu'ils puissent
réaliser leur péché
et qu'ils puissent
revenir à lui.
Ils n'avaient pas
encore réalisé ça
mais c'était
le but de Dieu.
C'est aussi
pour nous
une bonne réflexion
de voir aussi
de comprendre aussi
pourquoi
Dieu a pu
nous épargner.
Souvent
nous pouvons
avoir l'impression
d'avoir
beaucoup de chance
dans la vie.
Est-ce que
nous nous sommes
arrêtés un moment
pour réfléchir
à ces aspects ?
Pourquoi
j'ai été épargné ?
j'ai été épargné
de telles choses ?
Pourquoi
je suis vivant
jusqu'à présent ?
Et
nous avons tendance
souvent à prendre
des choses
pour acquises.
Nous avons tendance
à ne pas voir
la miséricorde
de Dieu
qui a permis
que nous soyons
encore présents.
Tu aurais pu être
terrassé par la maladie.
Nous avons perdu
beaucoup de personnes
qui sont mortes
lorsqu'il y a eu
la crise de Covid.
Nous avons perdu
beaucoup de personnes
qui sont mortes
dans notre cercle
de famille
ou de se repentir.
Ils n'étaient pas
dans cette réalité
parce qu'aujourd'hui
même lorsque
Dieu est en train
de parler
au travers d'Ézéchiel,
beaucoup sont sûrs
que Babylone
va tomber
et qu'ils vont être délivrés
et qu'ils pourront
revenir en Israël.
Beaucoup sont sûrs
que Jérusalem
ne va pas être détruite
parce que si Dieu
n'a pas détruit
Jérusalem
depuis plusieurs siècles,
si Dieu n'a pas
abandonné Israël
depuis plusieurs siècles,
il ne le fera pas
maintenant.
Donc beaucoup étaient sûrs
que le jugement
ne viendrait pas.
Mais Dieu était en train
de leur dire
et voilà pourquoi
Dieu l'annonce
à l'avance
par les prophètes.
Il annonce
la destruction
de Jérusalem
à cause du péché
d'idolâtrie
pour que le jour
où le jugement
arrivera,
ils ne puissent pas douter,
ils puissent réaliser
oui,
Dieu avait raison,
Dieu avait parlé
au travers de ses prophètes.
Donc Dieu était en train
de prévoir une grâce
pour ses fuyards
mais il était aussi
en train de prévoir
le temps
pour qu'ils puissent
méditer
sur ce qu'ils étaient
en train de vivre
et qu'ils puissent se repentir.
Malheureusement,
nous pouvons souvent
échapper à l'épée
du jugement de Dieu
et ne pas abandonner
le péché.
Nous pouvons échapper
à l'épée du jugement
de Dieu
et négliger
la grâce de Dieu.
On va considérer
un moment
qu'on ne doit rien
à Dieu,
on va considérer
même un moment
que nous trouvons
normal de péché
et du moment
que le jugement
de Dieu
n'est pas tombé
sur nous,
nous trouvons normal
de pouvoir
persévérer
dans un péché.
Et souvent,
beaucoup de personnes,
lorsqu'elles vont
prendre un temps
de repentance,
c'est lorsqu'elles vont
vivre maintenant
les conséquences
du péché
et parce qu'elles voudraient
même que ces conséquences
du péché s'arrêtent.
Non pas parce qu'elles
réalisent le péché
qu'elles ont commis
vis-à-vis de Dieu
mais c'est parce qu'elles
sont en train de vivre
les conséquences
alors elles se tournent
vers Dieu
pour demander pardon
afin qu'il arrête ça
mais ne veulent pas
arrêter le péché.
Nous devons chacun
de nous réfléchir
sur la patience
de Dieu
à notre égard
dans nos vies.
Ce reste d'Israël
était désigné
pour le salut
mais ce reste d'Israël
est une figure
du reste
que Dieu
a épargné
dans notre histoire
humaine plus générale
afin que nous puissions
expérimenter sa miséricorde
en étant sauvés
comme eux
au travers du don
de la repentance.
Là nous étions
sur ce
c'était ce deuxième point
de qu'est-ce que Dieu
voulait leur enseigner
à eux
et aux nations
alentours
et nous allons
un peu rentrer
dans le détail
je peux dire un peu
là c'est un peu
l'introduction
et ça va être
un peu long
donc je pense même
aujourd'hui
qu'on abordera
je ne sais pas
si on finira
tous ces points
mais ce que nous
devons comprendre
pourquoi Dieu
et qu'est-ce que
Dieu voulait leur enseigner
au travers
du fait
de les conserver
comme reste
pour eux
et pour les nations
alentours
la première chose
tout d'abord
l'occasion
que Dieu leur donnait
de se repentir
incluait un jugement
car ils étaient
emmenés
captifs
ou dispersés
mais
cette occasion
elle incluait
un jugement
mais elle incluait
aussi une miséricorde
c'est-à-dire que
Dieu les a
emmenés captifs
ou Dieu les a
dispersés
mais Dieu
est en train
d'exercer
sa miséricorde
parce que
ils avaient échappé
à la mort
à la famine
ils avaient échappé
à l'épée
à la maladie
ils avaient été
chassés de leur terre
mais Dieu
ne leur avait pas
ôté la vie
ou comme
le dit souvent
la Bible
Dieu ne les avait pas
retirés du faisceau
des vivants
notre Dieu
est juste
voilà pourquoi
quand nous avons
prié
au début
de la prédication
je rappelais
que
quand nous sommes
en train
d'aborder la parole
quand tu lis
la parole
ou que tu t'apprêtes
à écouter la parole
prie toujours
pour que Dieu
t'accorde
un coeur honnête
et un coeur bon
un coeur qui est honnête
c'est un coeur qui reconnaît
que Dieu est vrai
dans ce qu'il dit
c'est un coeur qui reconnaît
que Dieu est juste
dans les décisions
qu'il prend
notre Dieu est juste
dans les jugements
qu'il peut apporter
dans nos vies
mais lorsque nous voyons
le jugement de Dieu
dans nos vies
nous voyons aussi
son extrême miséricorde
nous voyons un moment
que Dieu
ne nous punit
mais Dieu ne nous punit
jamais à la hauteur
de ce que nous méritons
d'ailleurs c'est simple
la Bible nous dit
que le salaire du péché
c'est la mort
donc si tu pêches
normalement
tu es censé même
déjà mourir
et à un moment
il y a certains exemples
dans la Bible
où des personnes
ont péché
et immédiatement
elles ont été frappées
de mort
mais si aujourd'hui
tu pêches
et que tu es encore vivant
c'est parce que
Dieu use de miséricorde
afin que tu puisses
réaliser cette miséricorde
et que tu puisses
te repentir
et donc nous chrétiens
c'est très important
chacun de nous
peut traverser
des moments
très difficiles
dans nos vies
mais nous devons
nous souvenir
qu'au milieu
des difficultés
des vies
que nous traversons
nous voyons aussi
l'extrême
miséricorde de Dieu
la semaine dernière
nous avions parlé
lorsque Dieu prend
à témoin la création
en disant
moment
montagne
colline
écoutez
ce que l'éternel
est en train de dire
nous étions en train
de dire qu'à un moment
cette création
les moustiques
n'avaient pas été faits
pour te piquer la nuit
les moustiques
avaient été faits
pour que
aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être
inimaginable
pour chacun de nous
que nous regardions
des moustiques
avec joie
on se rend
en train de s'émerveiller
en voyant
les moustiques passer
ce serait très difficile
mais c'était le but
initial de Dieu
c'est-à-dire que
tu vois un moustique
ou que tu vois une mouche
et que tu puisses
te réjouir
de ce que Dieu a fait
mais à cause du péché
de l'homme
même la création
a été soumise au péché
et maintenant
à cause du péché
de l'homme
tes nuits peuvent être
difficiles
à cause des moustiques
mais nous devons
comprendre
que nous vivons
aussi bien chrétiens
que nous croyons
nous vivons
les conséquences
de notre péché
nous vivons
les conséquences
de la chute
étant descendants
d'Adam et Ève
qui ont péché
nous aussi
dès notre naissance
nous sommes déjà pécheurs
et nous vivons
les conséquences
de la chute
et donc à un moment
quand Dieu peut apporter
des jugements
dans notre vie
il est juste
dans tout ce qu'il peut faire
mais nous voyons
aussi la miséricorde
de Dieu
parce que nous méritions
même d'être
encore plus punis
que ça
mais nous voyons
la miséricorde
de Dieu
qui a été faite
jusqu'au point de donner
la vie de son fils
pour nous
et donc
quand Dieu
ne nous punit pas
à la hauteur
de ce que nous méritons
il le fait
afin que nous puissions
réaliser sa miséricorde
que nous puissions
nous repentir
et que nous puissions
comprendre
qu'il nous corrige
pour notre bien
Dieu résiste
aux orgueilleux
mais il fait grâce
aux humbles
les épreuves
que nous pouvons traverser
peuvent être aussi
de bonnes occasions
pour nos conversions
si vous regardez
même les vies
je me souviens
quand j'étais en Afrique
il y avait beaucoup
qui avaient
l'habitude
de dire
un moment
que si tu es bien
à l'aise dans ta vie
tu n'as pas besoin
d'aller à l'église
ce sont les pauvres
et les désespérés
qui vont à l'église
mais si tu es bien
mais Dieu
à un moment
va utiliser les épreuves
voilà pourquoi
Dieu va aussi utiliser
les épreuves
parce que l'homme
orgueilleux
quand Dieu bénit l'homme
l'homme prend pour acquis
les choses
qu'il lui a données
et à un moment
Dieu a besoin
de retirer ces choses aussi
pour que l'homme
comprenne
son besoin de Dieu
et donc
nous pouvons aussi témoigner
que les épreuves
que nous traversons
non seulement
ont été des occasions
pour notre conversion
mais elles sont encore
des occasions
pour nous rendre
conformes à Christ
beaucoup d'entre nous
peuvent le témoigner
et nous devons le prendre
comme une miséricorde
un passage
qui me touche beaucoup
si nous lisons
dans deux chroniques
je vais simplifier
mais
deux chroniques
chapitre 33
verset 1
et verset 10 à 13
je vais prendre
l'exemple de Manassé
alors Manassé
c'est le petit-fils
d'Ézéchias
du roi Ézéchias
Ézéchias a été
un roi pieux
et d'ailleurs
c'est un des rois
qui a été confronté
à la Syrie
qui avait même voulu
déjà envahir
le royaume du Juda
Dieu l'a épargné
Dieu a envoyé son ange
qui a frappé
l'armée du roi assyrien
et finalement
185 000 soldats
ont été tués
en toute une nuit
par un seul ange
et ils ont été délivrés
Ézéchias est mort
et quelques années plus tard
Manassé est arrivé
Manassé
c'est donc le passage
Manassé avait 12 ans
lorsqu'il devint roi
et il régna 55 ans
à Jérusalem
il fit ce qui est mal
aux yeux de l'Éternel
selon les abominations
des nations
que l'Éternel avait chassé
devant les enfants d'Israël
Manassé a été
un des rois
les plus impies
mais voyons
ce qu'il nous est dit
dans les versets
10 à 13
alors Dieu
va corriger
Manassé
va être
corrigé par Dieu
l'Éternel
parla à Manassé
et à son peuple
et ils n'y firent point
attention
alors l'Éternel
fit venir contre eux
les chefs de l'armée
du roi d'Assyrie
qui saisirent Manassé
et le mirent dans les fers
ils le lièrent
avec des chaînes d'airain
et le ménèrent
à Babylone
lorsqu'il fut
dans la détresse
il implora
l'Éternel
sans Dieu
et il s'humilia profondément
devant le Dieu
de ses pères
il lui adressa
ses prières
et l'Éternel
se laissant fléchir
exauça ses supplications
et le ramena
à Jérusalem
dans son royaume
et Manassé
reconnut
que l'Éternel
est Dieu
souvent nous allons
considérer
qu'à cause
de la vie
dissolue
que nous pouvons avoir
nous ne sommes pas
méritants
de la grâce de Dieu
nous ne sommes pas
méritants
de la grâce de Dieu
mais la grâce de Dieu
est offerte
à chacun d'entre nous
et notre besoin
lorsque Dieu permet
il n'y a personne
qui va pouvoir être heureux
ce que Dieu est en train
de souligner
au travers des idoles
qui étaient détruites
il est en train de dire
toutes les choses
ici bas
dans lesquelles
vous pouvez placer
votre espérance
ça peut être
la Vierge Marie
qu'on va adorer
ça peut être son travail
ça peut être ses enfants
ça peut être son épouse
des personnes
peuvent avoir
quelque chose
qui est en train
de se lever
contre la place
que Dieu devrait avoir
dans sa vie
mais Dieu dit à un moment
qu'aucune de ces choses
n'a la capacité
de nous apporter
de la satisfaction
aucune de ces choses
n'a la capacité
de pouvoir remplir
le vide
qu'il y a dans notre coeur
et nous devons donc
comprendre un moment
que même quand
nous pouvons avoir
toutes ces choses
et que nous ressentons
ce vide
c'est parce que Dieu
est en train de nous appeler
à la repentance
Dieu nous fait comprendre
le besoin que nous avons
de nous humilier
et de comprendre
un moment
que nous devons
tourner les regards
vers lui
qui est le seul Dieu
le deuxième point
c'est de voir
toujours
quand nous lisons
le verset 9
vos réchappés
se souviendront de moi
parmi les nations
où ils seront captifs
quelle serait la racine
de leur repentance
c'est ce qui vient
d'être lu
vos réchappés
se souviendront de moi
la racine de leur repentance
viendrait du souvenir
de l'éternel
ils avaient oublié Dieu
dans leur temps de paix
et dans leur temps
de prospérité
et maintenant
le souvenir
de leur seul Dieu
leur serait rappelé
dans les pays
où ils étaient captifs
donc comme je vous ai dit
il y en avait
qui avaient été
pris captifs
à Babylone
il y en avait
qui avaient fui en Égypte
mais le lien commun
qu'ils allaient avoir
c'est qu'ils allaient
eux qui avaient oublié Dieu
dans leur temps de prospérité
dans leur temps de paix
eux qui avaient oublié Dieu
et qui ne pensaient pas
à un moment
que Dieu puisse
se souvenir
de leur péché d'idolâtrie
maintenant
ils allaient se souvenir
de Dieu
dans les pays
où ils avaient été
conduits par Dieu
un exemple
qui nous permet
de comprendre cela
c'est quand nous pensons
à l'exemple
pour ceux qui connaissent
la parabole
du fils prodie
à un moment
c'est un exemple
très parlant
le fils prodigue
dont je donne
rapidement le contexte
c'est le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
qui prend un exemple
pour nous parler
un moment
de cet état du pécheur
qui s'éloigne de Dieu
mais à un moment
il ne trouve pas la paix
à un moment
il était parti
avec toute sa fortune
il a dilapidé
toute sa fortune
et lorsqu'il est
dans la plus totale misère
c'est là
il se souvient
de son père
le fils prodigue
c'est pendant
qu'il est en train
de donner
lorsqu'il est en train
d'être avec les porcs
il n'arrive même pas
à manger
il est même en train
de vouloir manger
la nourriture
que mangent les porcs
c'est là où il est
en train de se souvenir
de la maison
de son père
il est en train
de se souvenir
qu'il mangeait
à satiété
dans la maison
de son père
et c'est quand
il est dans
un pays lointain
donc le premier souvenir
quand Dieu est en train
de dire
quelle serait la racine
de leur repentance
c'était ce souvenir
de Dieu
c'était le premier acte
de leur repentance
ils allaient se souvenir
de Dieu
et nous pouvons même
dire par là
que le péché
c'est l'oubli
de Dieu
le péché
c'est oublier
ce que Dieu
nous commande
de faire
la repentance
naît du souvenir
de Dieu
et de l'obéissance
que nous lui devons
Dieu fait grâce
et cette grâce
nous trouve
nous rappelle
Dieu à l'esprit
et nous ramène
à lui
Jérémie
c'est extraordinaire
de voir que
et ça nous devons
toujours nous le rappeler
le principe
de beaucoup de religions
même le principe
lorsque certains
si on voulait
connaître un certain
il y a certains évangiles
où on va annoncer
un Dieu
de colère
qui est impitoyé
vis-à-vis du péché
et ce n'est pas faux
mais ils vont laisser
les personnes
dans cette condition
de détresse
ce n'est pas le cas
de Dieu
quand Dieu nous corrige
Dieu nous donne
aussi de l'espérance
Dieu nous corrige
pour que nous gardions
de l'espérance
en lui
Dieu nous corrige
afin que nous ayons
les yeux tournés
vers lui
mais
si à un moment
par exemple
nous avons eu nos parents
qui nous ont corrigés
et certains d'entre nous
ont eu des expériences
très difficiles
tu as eu tes parents
qui t'ont corrigé
d'une façon très sévère
et derrière
ils n'ont pas manifesté
d'amour
c'était juste
de te battre
pour ci ou pour ça
et tu en as gardé
un très mauvais souvenir
mais le Dieu
qui est notre père
c'est un Dieu
qui nous corrige
pour notre bien
mais c'est un Dieu aussi
qui nous manifeste
de l'amour
après la correction
et lorsque les prophètes
étaient en train
d'annoncer
la destruction
de Jérusalem
nous devons voir
que Dieu était déjà
aussi en train
d'annoncer
la restauration
de Jérusalem
quand les prophètes
annoncent
la destruction
d'Israël
Dieu est aussi
en train d'annoncer
non seulement la destruction
mais la restauration
quand leur cœur
va se tourner vers lui
Jérémie 3
verset 11 au verset 14
nous dit un moment
l'éternel me dit
l'infidèle Israël
paraît innocente
en comparaison
de la perfide Judas
va
crie ses paroles
vers le septentrion
et dit
reviens
infidèle Israël
dit l'éternel
je ne jetterai pas
sur vous
un regard sévère
car je suis miséricordieux
dit l'éternel
je ne garde pas
ma colère à toujours
reconnais seulement
ton iniquité
reconnais que tu as été
infidèle à l'éternel
ton Dieu
que tu as dirigé
ça et là
tes pas
vers
les dieux étrangers
sous tout arbre vert
et que tu n'as pas
écouté ma voix
dit l'éternel
vous voyez
Dieu met
en avant
en phase
et nous avons dit
à un moment
que le principal
problème d'Israël
et on va même dire
le principal problème
de l'homme
c'est le péché
d'idolâtrie
le premier principe
du péché
d'idolâtrie
c'est de placer
des choses
à la place
qui revient
à Dieu
dans nos vies
et lorsque nous
ouvrons
la porte
au péché
d'idolâtrie
nous ouvrons la porte
à de nombreux
autres péchés
quand Dieu est en train
de parler d'Israël
il n'est pas en train
de dire
votre problème
c'était tel ou tel péché
il est en train
de dire
à un moment
le problème d'Israël
c'était le fait
qu'ils avaient été
infidèles
en allant dans l'idolâtrie
et à partir du moment
ils avaient idolâtré
ils avaient adoré
des dieux étrangers
ils avaient apporté
le jugement
à partir du moment
ils avaient apporté
les dieux étrangers
tout le reste
de leur vie
partait
dans ce sens
de certains
autres péchés
que ce soit
la négligence
des orphelins
des veuves
toutes ces choses
parce que Dieu
est en train
de préciser
que si nous sommes
déjà en train
de respecter
ce commandement
d'aimer l'éternel
de tout notre cœur
âme et force
à partir de ce moment
nous fermons la porte
à de nombreux autres
péchés
dans notre vie
mais
donc il dit
à un moment
dans Jérémie
11 à 14
reconnais seulement
dans verset 13
ton iniquité
reconnais que tu as été
infidèle à l'éternel
ton Dieu
que tu as dirigé
ça et là
tes pas
vers les dieux étrangers
sous tout arbre vert
et que tu n'as pas
écouté ma voix
dit l'éternel
revenez
enfant rebelle
dit l'éternel
car je suis votre maître
je vous prendrai
un d'une ville
deux d'une famille
et je vous ramènerai
dans Sion
le fils prodigue
aussi s'est souvenu
de son père
il s'est rappelé
et quand il se souvient
de son père
il se souvient
qu'il avait péché
contre le ciel
et contre son père
la première chose
et vous voyez
ce que je disais
c'est que beaucoup
de personnes
à un moment
quand elles vont
se repentir
elles vont se repentir
non pas parce qu'elles
ont réalisé
qu'elles ont péché
contre Dieu
mais elles vont se repentir
parce qu'elles sont en train
de vivre
les conséquences du péché
et qu'elles aimeraient
que ce fardeau
soit enlevé
mais la Bible nous dit
le fils prodigue
va se rappeler
qu'il avait péché
contre le ciel
et contre le père
contre son père
notre repentance
doit venir
du souvenir
que nous avons eu
de l'affront
contre Dieu
d'abord
quand nous péchons
nous nous souvenons
que nous avons
commis un affront
contre Dieu
et ensuite nous nous souvenons
aussi que nous avons
fait du mal
à notre prochain
beaucoup vont se repentir
parce qu'à un moment
ils ne veulent pas
reconnaître
qu'ils ont fait
un affront
contre Dieu
parce que je ne voudrais pas
dire qu'ils ont fait
du mal à Dieu
Dieu n'est pas atteint
par notre péché
par les conséquences
de nos péchés
Dieu est saint
et d'ailleurs
quand Dieu nous demande
même un moment
de ne pas pécher
c'est pour notre bien
et le bien
de notre prochain
mais le mal
n'atteint pas Dieu
et donc je ne vais même
pas dire
c'est un affront
ce n'est pas que nous avons
fait du mal à Dieu
c'est que nous avons
commis un affront
contre Dieu
et donc certaines personnes
vont lorsqu'elles ont fait
du mal
parce qu'elles veulent
absolument
pouvoir être restaurées
parce qu'elles veulent
que lors
cette image
que les autres personnes
ont d'elles
puissent être restaurées
elles vont demander
pardon
à personne
parce qu'elles veulent
absolument
que cela s'arrête
mais ne réalisent pas
qu'elles ont péché
contre Dieu
et je me souviens
une fois
qu'il y avait quelqu'un
qui avait
qui avait fait du mal
à une personne
et il exigeait
que la personne
à qui il demandait
pardon
lui pardonne
et à un moment
on lui a fait comprendre
mais tu n'es pas
dans le droit
d'exiger
tu es en train
de demander pardon
et tu ne dois pas
être dans l'exigence
que cette personne
te pardonne
parce que tu lui as
fait cet acte
mais il était en train
de le faire
parce qu'il voulait
calmer sa conscience
il réalisait l'affront
il réalisait
les conséquences
que lui était en train
de vivre
à cause de ce problème
vis-à-vis de cette personne
il voulait juste
restaurer cette image
mais ne réalisait pas
l'affront
qu'il avait fait à Dieu
notre repentance
doit d'abord
souvenir de l'affront
que nous avons fait à Dieu
par une pratique
idolâtre
et pécheresse
et ensuite
nous pouvons aussi
nous souvenir du mal
que nous avons fait
contre notre prochain
et si nécessaire
demander pardon
donc
j'ai pris l'exemple
du fils prodigue
où la Bible souligne bien
il avait péché
contre le ciel
et contre lui
et Paul va nous dire
dans Romains 6
verset 20 à 21
car lorsque nous étions
esclaves
du péché
nous portions des fruits
dont nous rougissons
encore aujourd'hui
et la fin de tout cela
était la mort
nous ne pouvons pas
évoquer
notre vie de péché
et trouver une joie
dans ce que nous étions
en train de faire
quand nous allons
nous repentir
en réalisant
que nous avons fait
un affront
contre Dieu
aucun de nous
ne pourra trouver
que la vie de péché
qu'il a même vécu
avant que Dieu
ne le sauve
il puisse y trouver
une joie
quelconque
tout comme Israël
nous sommes éloignés
de Dieu
pour servir des idoles
que nous nous sommes fabriqués
ce sont des idoles
qui peuvent être de chair
comme je vous ai dit
on peut idolâtrer
ses enfants
on peut
d'ailleurs souvent
on a vu un grand boom
des
beaucoup de parents
maintenant
des enfants HPI
je me dis à un moment
que là aussi
on est parti
dans une forme d'idolâtrie
où souvent ton enfant
est pénible
pour les autres
mais il est un génie pour toi
donc souvent
nos idoles
peuvent être
des idoles de chair
ça peut être
le mari
les enfants
des amitiés
même des frères
de l'église
ça peut être
des idoles de bois
de métal
ça peut être
des idoles
qui sont imaginées
mais toutes ces choses
nous ont amené
à adorer la créature
au lieu du créateur
et donc pour nous
c'est nécessaire
qu'un examen régulier
de nos cœurs
s'impose tout le temps
car nous avons
tellement cette facilité
à inverser
l'ordre de priorité
qui a été établi
par Dieu
l'ordre de priorité
quand nous lisons
la parole
c'est Dieu
les hommes
et moi
mais aujourd'hui
dans la vie
de l'homme
pécheur
c'est moi
les hommes
et Dieu
et même là
je vais même dire
on va même dire
c'est moi
dans certaines considérations
c'est juste
je pense juste à moi
les autres
et Dieu
ce n'est pas mon problème
la racine
de la repentance
du peuple
de Dieu
serait que
leur cœur
se souvienne
de Dieu
mais la racine
de leur péché
tout comme
la racine
de nos péchés
à nous
ce sont des cœurs
qui oublient
et qui s'éloignent
de Dieu
l'adoration
envers Dieu
ne se fait pas seulement
par des lèvres
qui se disent
le servir
et l'aimer
elle se fait en plus
par un engagement
de nos émotions
de notre volonté
par un engagement
de nos pensées
si notre engagement
à aimer Dieu
se limite aux paroles
sans y engager
notre cœur
nous sommes dans
un adultère spirituel
c'est le principe
de l'adultère spirituel
car nous avons choisi
d'adorer la créature
au lieu du créateur
nous avons choisi
d'aimer
je vais dire dans ce cas
la créature
au lieu du créateur
parce que le cœur
est corrompu
alors les yeux
se tournent
vers les idoles
souvent nous allons
trouver des circonstances
atteignantes
pour justifier
des péchés
en soulignant
un moment
que c'est les effets extérieurs
qui nous ont amené
à réagir
comme nous réagissons
mais ce que la Bible
nous dit
c'est la racine
de notre cœur
qui nous amène
à manifester
ce que nous manifestons
certaines personnes
vont dire
je suis devenu
insensible et froid
parce que les gens
m'ont fait tellement de mal
non
tu es devenu
insensible et froid
parce que tu as accepté
le péché
tu as accepté
un péché
que Dieu condamne
vis-à-vis de son prochain
et maintenant
c'est parti
de la racine
de ton cœur
et ça se manifeste
à l'extérieur
et voilà pourquoi
souvent nous disons
que ce ne sont pas
les circonstances
qui définissent
qui vont définir
notre façon d'agir
c'est déjà
les circonstances
montrent juste
l'état de notre cœur
on peut chercher
à trouver
des justifications
aux circonstances
en disant
c'est parce que
j'ai vécu
telle ou telle chose
que je suis comme ça
mais la réalité
à un moment
c'est parce que
ça montre juste
l'état de notre cœur
et donc si
le cœur
est déjà corrompu
alors les yeux
se tourneront
vers les idoles
alors les yeux
vont se fabriquer
une idole
la convoitise
ne vient pas
juste des yeux
la convoitise
unique
ils pleureront
amèrement sur lui
comme on pleure
sur un premier-né
c'est l'esprit
de Dieu
qui produit
la repentance
et l'humilité
pour sauver
nous devons
comprendre
j'ai discuté
avec des personnes
et il y a une personne
qui a dit
elle a beaucoup de mal
à accepter
le principe
que ce soit Dieu
qui produise en nous
la repentance
que ce soit Dieu
qui produise en nous
le salut
et on est souvent
dans ce principe
et je veux vous dire
toutes les religions
demandent à l'homme
de faire un effort
pour trouver
la satisfaction
auprès du Dieu
qui le sert
le christianisme
est la seule religion
qui va dire
à un moment
que tout ce que tu peux apporter
ne sert à rien
c'est Dieu seul
qui peut te sauver
et donc nous devons
comprendre à un moment
que des cadavres
de cadavres
ne peuvent pas
provenir à la vie
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
en disant à un moment
que
l'idolâtrie
vient de la corruption
de notre coeur
elle ne vient pas
d'éléments extérieurs
qui nous ont corrompus
donc
quand vous allez entendre
à un moment
que l'homme n'est bon
c'est la société
qui le rend
mauvais
c'est un mensonge
diabolique
la vérité
c'est que
l'homme n'est pécheur
et il est en train
d'apporter le péché
dans le monde
pour ceux
qui ont des enfants
regarder
des bébés
quand il y a un bébé
qui prend le sein
à un moment
quand il commence
à avoir ses dents
il va mordre
et quand la mère
fait aïe
il est content
il sourit
il rigole
mais ça c'est déjà
une manifestation
c'est une manifestation
de péché
et souvent
on va considérer
un moment
non
mais
la chose qu'il y a
c'est que nous
devons comprendre
que ça vient de nous
et ça se reflète
sur l'extérieur
et donc si
nous avons des cœurs
corrompus
comment ces cœurs
auraient pu produire
la vie
c'est impossible
c'est Dieu seul
qui produit la repentance
qui produit l'humilité
pour sauver
c'est Dieu seul
qui change le cœur
un cœur
de corruption
pour en faire
un cœur
rempli
de la parole
de l'éternel
Dieu promet
et donc nous voyons
ce que nous venons
de lire
dans Zacharie 12
verset 10
il est en train
de dire
je vous ai détruit
je vous apporte
ce jugement
mais j'épargnerai
un reste
pour que vous
puissiez vous souvenir
de moi
j'épargnerai un reste
afin qu'il apporte
un esprit de grâce
et de supplication
il va épargner un reste
afin que ce reste
puisse voir
le sauveur des nations
Dieu promet
un renouvellement
de l'alliance
et c'est ça qui est beau
et d'ailleurs
là aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas encore
très visible
dans cette première partie
des équels
mais quand nous allons
poursuivre
Dieu est en train
de rappeler
à un moment
qu'Israël
n'avait pas
la capacité
de respecter
la loi
voilà pourquoi
aussi ce jugement
arrive
mais il est en train
de promettre
vous n'avez pas été
capable de respecter
la loi
c'était pour vous
le faire comprendre
ce jugement
c'est pour vous faire
comprendre
à un moment
vous vous êtes basé
sur le fait
que vos efforts
peuvent vous donner
le salut
mais ce n'est pas
le cas
il faut que vous
compreniez
que c'est moi seul
qui peux vous sauver
il fallait qu'ils comprennent
qu'ils devaient
accueillir
le Messie
qui allait les sauver
et donc
Dieu promet
qu'il va établir
une alliance
encore plus excellente
que cette ancienne alliance
qu'il n'avait pas pu
respecter
et que dans cette alliance
son esprit
allait renouveler
leur coeur
son esprit
allait produire
un esprit
de grâce
et de supplication
de façon métaphorique
vous voyez
il a dit un moment
et ils tourneront
les regards vers moi
celui qu'ils ont percé
de façon métaphorique
Dieu souligne
qu'il a été percé
par l'infidélité
du peuple d'Israël
par la volonté
de Dieu
cette métaphore
dont il parle
elle est devine réelle
en la personne de Christ
et là il dit un moment
ils tourneront
les regards vers moi
celui qu'ils ont percé
et pleureront
sur lui
comme on pleure
sur un fils unique
quiconque voit le fils
et croit en lui
aura la vie éternelle
et Christ le résistera
au dernier jour
ce n'est pas une métaphore
ce n'est pas un mythe
ce n'est pas une légende
c'est une réalité
nous allons
nous arrêter là
parce qu'il y avait
encore d'autres points
nous allons nous arrêter
là aujourd'hui
mais en conclusion
ce que nous devons
aussi retenir
dans cet exemple
que Dieu est en train
de souligner
lorsqu'il épargne
un reste
pour que ce reste
puisse se souvenir
de l'éternel
que ce reste
puisse se repentir
et revenir à Dieu
et être restauré à Dieu
l'encouragement
il est le même
que nous
nous puissions
prendre garde
à ne pas avoir
de coeur idolâtre
que nous puissions
prendre garde
à ne pas avoir
de coeur mauvais
que nous puissions
prendre garde
à ne pas avoir
des coeurs incrédules
qui se détournent de Dieu
la vérité qu'il y a
c'est que nous aurons
toujours un moment
à pécher
nous aurons toujours
un moment
à nous éloigner
comme je l'ai dit
nous allons oublier Dieu
d'une certaine façon
mais nous devons
toujours réaliser
que si nous ne sommes
pas frappés
si nous ne sommes pas
frappés
le salaire du péché
c'est la mort
si je ne suis pas mort
c'est parce que Dieu
me laisse un temps
de repentance
nous pouvons
traverser des batailles
vis-à-vis du péché
mais nous ne devons pas
laisser notre coeur
être endurci
par le péché
nous pouvons traverser
des batailles
vis-à-vis du péché
mais nous ne devons pas
trouver le péché normal
dans notre vie
nous pouvons traverser
des batailles
vis-à-vis du péché
qui sont difficiles
mais nous ne devons pas
trouver des excuses
pour justifier ce péché
et si nous sommes en train
de laisser le péché
nous trouvons normal
un péché dans notre vie
nous sommes en train
d'accepter
d'être endurcis
par ce péché
ou nous ne nous repentons
pas
nous ne demandons pas
pardon à Dieu
si nous trouvons normal
nous cherchons
des excuses
pour le justifier
nous sommes en train
de produire un coeur
qui est idolâtre
nous sommes en train
de produire un coeur
qui est mauvais
et incrédule
et c'est un coeur
qui sera frappé
par le jugement de Dieu
d'une certaine façon
quand nous allons
examiner nos coeurs
nous allons toujours voir
la facilité
que l'homme a
de pouvoir substituer
d'ailleurs souvent
on dit
de façon générale
on dit qu'il est
beaucoup plus facile
de détruire
que de construire
nous avons beaucoup
plus de facilité
à aller dans un sens
de destruction
que dans un sens
de construction
nous avons beaucoup
plus de facilité
c'est vrai que
en tant que croyant
il nous faut
beaucoup d'efforts
pour pêcher
parce qu'à un moment
à cause des coeurs
régénérés
que Dieu a produit
au travers
de l'oeuvre de Christ
la parole de Dieu
est inscrite
dans nos coeurs
et donc quand je pêche
je suis conscient
de ce que je suis
en train de faire
et voilà pourquoi
je ne me dois même pas
de chercher des excuses
je me dois de demander
pardon à Dieu
mais si nous sommes
conscients à un moment
que nous sommes en train
de porter certains aspects
d'idolâtrie
dans notre vie
nous devons réaliser
chaque fois
notre besoin de Christ
nous devons alors
chaque fois
lever les yeux
et regarder
à celui qui a été crucifié
à cause de notre
coeur idolâtre
nous qui sommes
croyants
et qui sommes devenus
participants
à la nature divine
nous devons retenir
fermement
jusqu'à la fin
l'assurance
que nous avions
au commencement
nos coeurs
lorsque nous avons été
touchés par le péché
nous avons réalisé
que notre affront
ne constituait pas
juste un affront
contre les gens
ou contre nous-mêmes
nous avons d'abord
réalisé
que notre péché
était un affront
contre Dieu
et nous devons
persévérer dans cela
lorsque tu es en train
de demander pardon
à ta femme
quand tu l'as
offensé
ou tu l'as blessé
tu ne dois pas
demander pardon
parce que tu espères
juste qu'elle puisse
se remettre
à te soutenir
dans certaines choses
qu'elle puisse
recommencer à te préparer
des plats que tu aimes
et parce qu'à cause
de l'affront
tu ne manges plus
à ta faim
et tu te repends
ce n'est pas ça
la première chose
c'est que tu dois
réaliser que tu as
échoué vis-à-vis de Dieu
la première chose
quand tu es en train
d'offenser ta femme
que tu es en train
de blesser ta femme
tu as d'abord péché
contre Dieu
et ensuite tu as péché
contre elle
et donc notre repentance
doit aussi aller
dans ce sens d'ordre
nous devons croire
que la passance de Dieu
est notre salut
nous devons rester
sur nos gardes
nous devons rejeter
l'idolâtrie
nous devons être
rejeter l'idolâtrie
avec beaucoup de fermeté
avec le fait
que la parole
soit toujours en train
d'être dans notre souvenir
mais nous devons
continuer à croître
dans la grâce
et dans la connaissance
de notre Seigneur Jésus Christ
la façon
la façon de croître
dans la grâce
et dans la connaissance
de notre Seigneur Jésus Christ
il n'y a pas mille façons
la parole de Dieu
nous dit
un moment ta parole
est une lampe
à mes pieds
une lumière
sur mon sentier
si la parole de Dieu
n'est pas en train
d'éclairer notre vie
alors ce sont les ténèbres
qui le feront
alors nous allons être
dans un coeur
d'idolâtrie
mais si la parole de Dieu
est en train d'éclairer
notre vie
le péché ne sera jamais
une occasion
pour nous détourner
de Dieu
le péché sera une occasion
pour nous rappeler
l'extrême miséricorde
de Dieu
le péché sera une occasion
pour nous rappeler
le jugement de Dieu
parce qu'il est saint
mais il sera aussi
une occasion
pour nous rappeler
la miséricorde de Dieu
parce qu'il est juste
et il est aimant
pour nous rappeler
le péché